(clearing throat)
- You go back to the intersection,
you make a left at the
dead tree, you're welcome.
- What? No. I'm not lost.
- Trust me you are.
- Ha ha, funny, say, nice boat,
any chance you might
actually get on it today?
- What was that?
- New postman, Smeerensburg,
which is on an island,
which is surrounded by water,
which I need a boat to
get to, which you have.
Are we starting to connect the dots?
- Hmm-mm.
- Is the weather always like this?
- Eh, we having a bit of a heatwave.
- Where is everyone?
- Everyone?
- I thought there would be
some sort of a reception.
- Oh. Right, right the reception,
of course the reception.
It's good you reminded me.
You just ring the bell over there,
and then then reception will start.
- The bell?
- Yep. Give it a go, and they'll come out.
Why they'll have a band, hors d'oeuvres
and a, and a key to the city,
all that reception stuff.
- Really? Out here.
- Why of course.
Well it's not everyday they
get a brand new postman
from the big city.
(bell ringing)
(dramatic orchestral music)
(yelling)
- What's happening?!
- Alright, I'm gonna just
take wild guess here.
You are the latest mailman
and the ferryman tricked you
into ringing the battle-bell.
- Ah there you are!
I'd wondered where you'd
scurried off to, come on sport!
- What happened here?
- Oh. Um. Colorful local traditions.
Quirky folklore, that kinda thing.
All part of this quaint
town's vibrant culture.
(orchestral music)
- Home, sweet home.
(chickens clucking)
- Well, lots of nice, natural light,
rustic touches, central
air and panoramic views,
perfect for animal lovers.
Enjoy.
- Wait, wait.
Okay, get low, don't panic, don't panic.
- Ah, I guess that's why
they call it snail mail.
(dogs barking)
- Ah. Good puppies, good puppies. Ah, ah.
- And that must be the express mail.
- Is this is a bad time, I
can see you're pretty swamped.
(sigh)
Don't you have a job or something?
- Why sure I do.
I'm here to pick up all the outgoing mail.
So, where is it?
Now you're gonna have to help
me with the heavier bags.
Bad back don't you know?
- Man, I hate you.
- I know.
So eh, where, where is the mail anyway?
What do you keep it in a
different room now or something?
What about if I walk around the room,
if I get close to the
mail, you say warmer.
And if I'm getting further
from the mail, you say colder.
And then...
- What's that?
- What? Oh, the Woodsman's cabin?
- Yeah. Does someone live there?
- Oh sure. Yeah you
should definitely drop by,
nice fella, loves visitors.
- Jesper Johansson, postman.
We've never properly...
Oh uh.
- Ah. Young love.
Takes me back you know.
The intense looks, the
palpitation of the heart.
The whimpering, the
soiling of the pants, no.
I can't relate to so much of.
(sigh)
mwaa mwaa mwaa mwaa!